Кібератаки, що сталися цього тижня,
підкреслюють важливість підтримки,
яку НАТО надає Україні для посилення її кібербезпеки.
У цьому переконує генсек Альянсу Єнс Столтенберг.
DW дізналася, що саме він має на увазі.
НАТО створило цільовий фонд для кіберзахисту,
з якого ми фінансуємо програми та іншу діяльність.
Експерти НАТО надають Україні допомогу
для покращення її кібербезпеки.
Три роки тому на саміті НАТО в Уельсі
Альянс вирішив запустити нові програми для розвитку співпраці з Україною.
Було створено 6 цільових фондів.
Країни-члени НАТО фінансують їх
на добровільній основі
або надають іншу допомогу.
Один з цих фондів призначений саме для кіберзахисту України.
Його спонсорують 8 країн-членів НАТО під керівництвом Румунії.
За цей час вже зібрали 965 тисяч євро.
Ці кошти йдуть для підвищення кваліфікації
українських ІТ-експертів,
а також на встановлення сучасного обладнання
для захисту урядових комп’ютерів та комунікаційних систем.
Ця програма надає гранти
для різноманітних наукових проектів співпраці з НАТО,
проведення семінарів і тренінгів.
Одна з головних тем і є кібербезпека.
За три роки понад 280 молодих вчених з України
взяли участь у цій програмі.
Крім того, було запроваджено 11 нових напрямків співробітництва.
Тож, Україна нині отримує найбільше допомоги від цієї програми
порівняно з іншими державами-партнерами НАТО.
НАТО долучило Україну
до спеціальної платформи обміну інформацією
про шкідливий софт - програмне забезпечення, яке шпигує або
псує роботу комп’ютерних систем.
Тож, у режимі реально часу Україна може отримувати
від натівських партнерів сповіщення про кібератаки
та характеристики шкідливих програм.
Втім, від вірусу "Петя" це не врятувало.